they want you to know that they care
about the children they're going to
remind you as often as possible that
everything they do
they do for the kids
if you work hard
you can do better and pass on even
greater opportunities for your children
the people must be able to decide our
country's future
to determine your future the future of
your children it's about the children
the children the children the children
but in practice the children are just
props in their quest for more control
more power for bureaucrats and less for
parents
so when girls were raped in two separate
schools in northern virginia within
months of each other liberal school
administrators did their best to cover
it up
and when a father of one of the victims
came to a school board meeting to voice
concerns about safety at that loudoun
county high school they arrested him it
was absolutely disgusting i can't
believe it's america
the father appeared on the angle to
describe the orwellian experience
my daughter was sexually assaulted at
the end of school
in may of last year
and
you know
i went to the school board meeting you
know to see what was going on i tried to
tell the lady what had happened to my
daughter and
she looked me dead in the face and said
that's not what happened started in on
me again and threatened my family
business my livelihood next thing i know
i'm tackled to the ground
i
i'm just shocked
and
horrified
we all were horrified and as a parent i
found this story to be extremely
upsetting
both the crime that was committed
against this young woman and the effort
to vilify the family
of the young woman the female victim
and it seems to get
worse every day former president obama
rolled into richmond virginia over the
weekend to stump for terry mcauliffe
he's running for governor again and made
the mistake of dismissing concern about
the loudoun county crimes
we don't have time
to be
wasting
on these phony trumped-up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media's pedals to juice
their ratings that's not what you need
virginia
instead of forcing our communities to
cut back at a time when we're just
starting to recover we should be doing
more to support people who are educating
our kids and keeping our neighborhoods
safe
neighborhoods safe barack the democrats
can't even keep their school restrooms
safe
because they're far more worried about
the political repercussions than the
health and safety of the students in
this saga and that goes double for the
media goon squad
now i'm young enough to remember that
when liberal journalists over at the
washington post used to believe that it
was reprehensible for a defendant to use
the victim's sexual history to impeach
her credibility
well that's exactly what happened in
this case the girl apparently admitted
in court that she previously had had a
consensual relationship with her
attacker and that they even had agreed
to meet in the bathroom where the attack
occurred
washington post reporter justin juvenal
shall be juvenile while not mentioning
the name of the victim or her attacker
published these details he then followed
it up with a tweet clearly trying to
throw shade on the judge's decision the
chief judge in juvenile court who heard
all the evidence in the case decided
that the accused male teenager who wore
a skirt
did commit the sexual assault
but it seems the reporter wasn't happy
with that
now my question is
where are all the women who've stood up
for professed victims in the past
well let's remember their words
how many women and men are there across
this country who are being harassed and
they have no recourse and no voice that
has got to stop this is exactly why
women don't feel comfortable coming
forward and telling their stories we
have to create a safe space for women to
be able to come forward
well the washington post used to believe
also that no means no
but now who wants women especially
concerned mothers to shut up and go away
the very democrats who claim to be the
metoo defenders
now even kids are realizing that their
schools are a mess students at multiple
area high schools participated in
walkouts today to protest for safer
schools after the loudoun county school
board officials originally denied that
these attacks ever had occurred
now parents are justifiably fed up
the latest non-fake outrage involves
loudoun county's requirement that
parents must sign an nda a
non-disclosure agreement
to view part of its new race and equity
curriculum
now as part as a part of the school's
broader equity agenda the district spent
approximately seven thousand seven
hundred dollars to become a licensed
user of something called second step
programs a branch of the left-leaning
non-profit organization committee for
children
according to a copy of the nda style
form eligible parents at the lcps
must sign the document
to view the second step curriculum
all this board members who are by the
way attacking parental rights
in this case making them sign some
agreement that they're not going to talk
about it have to be defeated all of them
have to be thrown out on there you know
what's next go around
the campaign against parental
involvement in schools is being led us
not surprisingly by left-wing activists
like jack schneider and jennifer
berkshire writing in the washington post
parents claim they have the right to
shape their kid's school curriculum they
don't
to turn over all decisions to parents
would risk inhibiting the ability of
young people to think independently oh
it's lovely well naturally randy
weingarten the odious head of the
american federation of teachers
loved this anti-parent take tweeting
great peace on parents rights in public
schools
that's funny because by parents rights
she means the right to step aside and
let the experts control it all
who on earth would tolerate this respect
parents you're paying the bills here why
accept the abuse
and by the way this will only make
matters worse in schools where parents
have started their own walkouts that are
permanent
loudoun county is growing in population
but its school enrollment is dropping
meaning the schools are losing state
funding good
and the uber rich and ultra liberal
fairfax county public schools right
outside of d.c
are also seeing trouble on the horizon
all of last year we warned them that if
they kept their schools closed for
in-person learning while dumbing down
their curriculum with anti-racism and
equity parents would start pulling their
kids out and that's exactly what's
happened
the district is still down 10
000 students from their pre-pandemic
levels
now
what happened well they moved their
children to private or parochial schools
others opted for homeschooling others
went to areas of the country where
schools were operating in person
and yet school leaders according to this
piece acknowledge that when it comes to
students who had been in classrooms
pre-pandemic
they say they have no idea where they've
gone well they haven't they haven't been
disappeared by a musician a magician my
goodness
and these people who don't know where
the kids have gone
are in charge of your kids education
this is absolutely terrifying
but don't worry
their priorities include paring back on
ap courses and mandating that athletes
get the vaccination
parents are not just walking out on
these radical school administrators they
want to throw them all out
our schools are too important our kids
are too important we can't sit back and
just assume that everybody else is going
to take care of this we have phenomenal
teachers but it's the leadership i
haven't heard mcauliffe say you know hey
i'm going to go and investigate what's
happening in the schools but i did hear
young say that so why don't we give him
a shot how did you feel about him saying
the former governor saying parents
shouldn't be involved
my head honestly was about to explode
when i heard that i thought are you
kidding me
and this week glen younkin dropped an ad
reminding everyone that mcauliffe has
had a long history of fighting parental
rights and education
he vetoed a bill when he was governor
the first time back in 2016 that would
have given students the right to opt out
of assignments containing sexually
explicit content
it was bipartisan it gave parents a say
the option to choose an alternative for
my children but then governor terry
mcauliffe vetoed it twice he doesn't
think parents should have a say he said
that he shut us out
that's a devastating ad these are not
phony culture wars they're not phony
culture warriors
this is about who has the final say over
the present and future of our kids
education
this is about whom you trust to keep
your children safe when it's school
woke activists who are masquerading as
teachers or administrators
obviously can't be trusted
they have other priorities
the walkouts we saw today in virginia
are only the beginning
the democratic party is about to
experience what a political walk out
across america feels like
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else